in herzl scott mcgrath
and to everywhere dear young innovators
thank you for the invitation to address
your festival
and field anchor bundes president liber
alexander van der been
phil
i know 2020 was particularly challenging
for young people
it will be remembered as the year of
lockdowns
and confinements it was a very
difficult year for startups and
entrepreneurs
but there lies a chance in every crisis
and 2020 has also showcased
the power of digital technology to learn
to work to keep in touch
we would have met today in the city of
graz
this is not possible but instead of
cancelling the whole event you now will
present
projects and discuss on screen the
pandemic has demonstrated the potential
of digital innovation
to improve our health and well-being one
example
we are currently purchasing 200 death
infection
robots they can support hospital staff
working day after day on the coronavirus
front line
and better health and well-being is just
one of the 17
un sustainable development goals that
you
young innovators seek to address
let me tell you the european union is a
great place
to start up and grow successful european
young innovators alumni
are proof of that i think of
be my eyes the danish app it connects
blind
people with volunteers who help them via
video call
or think of ecosia the german search
engine that spends most of its revenues
on planting trees
and many more fascinating ideas
i was truly impressed by the 16 leading
projects of this year's edition
from culture to green energy
from health to inclusion but also from
youth to education
each of them shows how digital
innovation can help
solve the problems of our times and this
is why i'm glad the commission could
support this festival
and other events you are organizing with
our europe for citizens
program and europe
is doing more to help turn ideas into
innovation
we have set up a european innovation
council
around 10 billion euros will be
available during the next years
to fund small and medium-sized
enterprises
with high risk but high potential
we will support innovation projects from
several european countries
and we will offer coaching matchmaking
and help to set up a company
and europe is fighting the economic
impact of the crisis on
all fronts we organized the big
hashtag eu vs virus hackathon
to support the recovery 117
innovative solutions were selected as
winners
and we just invited startups to a
digital innovation challenge to create
new services based on
open solutions provided by the
commissions
these are just a few examples the
european union is putting
in place an entire ecosystem
to give entrepreneurs every opportunity
to become
world leading companies
in europe we want to be the global
leader of a digital transformation
that benefits society
this means setting our own rules and
standards
consistent with our values
one area where this is particularly
important
is artificial intelligence ai
can help us address many of the
sustainable development goals
take affordable medicine or better
education
take sustainable agriculture or cleaner
transport
at the same time ai raises
important ethical questions
we want european standards and values to
be applied in a.i
used in europe in particular
when complex ai solutions are deployed
in sensitive areas like for example
health care
or public services or employment
and let me give you another example the
pandemic has
shown the enormous potential of digital
services
but we also saw the challenges many
users
fell victims to online scams
disinformation is widespread and
businesses are increasingly dependent on
platforms to reach customers
so we have to ensure a safe
digital space where the rights of
europeans are protected
and where businesses can innovate grow
and compete on fair terms
no matter where whether it is an app
store
social media or an online marketplace
and this is why we need to upgrade our
e-commerce rules which
date actually from a time when most of
you
entered primary school don't get me
wrong
we will make sure not to stifle
innovation and not to put at risk the
benefits
that platforms have brought some
platforms are
vital public spaces for free expression
platforms enable smaller companies to
reach customers more easily
but we want that startups can compete
fairly without adding unnecessary burden
we're aiming for more sustainable more
digital
more prosperous economy and society
the transition we strive to achieve
needs
everybody and this is why initiatives
like the young innovators
are vital you are the ones who
connect cooperate and who create bonds
across europe and beyond
we need your ideas to drive innovation
in which people can trust
to ensure our digital leadership and to
shape europe's future
your future i wish you
all young innovators a very successful
festival thank you